can you say anything about the response
to uh Paparazzi Chase involving Prince
Harry and uh and his wife last night
pretty scary apparently two NYPD
officers involved we all know the
history with that family here what do
you know about that what can you tell if
New Yorkers and about that you know it's
clear that uh the
uh you know the Press uh paparazzi's you
know they want to get the right shot
they want to get the right story but
Public Safety must always be at the
Forefront of my The Briefing I received
you know two of our offices could have
been injured New York City is different
from a small town somewhere you
shouldn't be speeding anywhere but this
is a densely populated city and I think
all of us I don't think there's many of
us who don't recall how
uh how the his mom died and it would be
horrific to lose the innocent bystander
during a chase like this and something
to have happened to them as well so I
think we have to be extremely
responsible I thought that was a bit
Reckless and irresponsible
I'm going to be brief um in depth later
on today and to get the exact time frame
of how long I would find it hard to
believe that there was a two-hour
high-speed chase that would be finding
it hard to believe but we will find out
the exact duration of it but if it's uh
10 minutes a 10 minute Chase is
extremely dangerous in New York City we
have a lot of traffic a lot of movement
a lot of people are using our streets of
any type of high-speed chase that
involves something of that nature is
inappropriate you know police do it
under limited circumstances when they're
going after violent people but to do it
because you want to get the right shot
can turn out to be a place where people
can be harmed in a real way
Miss man